um sensibility or sensitivity is being
raised to a higher level and Hegel makes
a little aside here at this point which
is rather telling and I think it's
something that applies well to his own
time but we might also consider how
people use this sort of terminology
not not Latin terminology but but other
terminology in our own time so he says
these are expressions which translate
sensuous facts into Latin now that's an
interesting thing to say
they're not translating sensuous facts
into the notion
or even into the objects of the
understanding per se
he says they translate sensuous facts
what we might call the language of
perception into a language that we use
to articulate it right so if we think of
languages in this respect as is not
living languages at that time Latin was
used as a scientific language right and
as it still was for quite a while after
handle
if we think of language as kind of an
artificial system for classifying for
operating on things something that is of
the understanding
it's almost like a code right but it's
not a code used by living beings to you
know communicate about everything it's
only used for this this specific sort of
issue or matter and so when we translate
it as we do in that way
We're translating it into something that
makes us feel as if somehow we're
getting at the the reality of it
um but it's it's really just providing
us with another
something external really something that
doesn't get at the heart of what it is
that we're talking about
this is a problem that has been going on
for a long time people use jargon and
substitutes jargon for actual thinking
about things and they think through
jargon uh in in business language you
see a lot of that we're going to drill
down you know that's a very popular
phrase at this time five years from now
that's going to be very outmoded
um you know there's all sorts of trendy
things that people say and you're kind
of you know you can get a sense of what
they're supposed to mean but they can
mean all sorts of different things
because there really is no no uh genuine
meaning backing it uh you know that you
can you can point to nothing that the
understanding can really latch onto it
soothes the understanding it's very much
like what Hagel was calling description
much earlier on okay
this is where we get very metaphysical
and some of the the questions that
people have been asking about you know
what is the for itself and what is the
in itself you know oftentimes trying to
trying to you know aim for something
with with as simple as what sart said
about it and being in melting this
I've always responded look for itself
and in itself don't always mean exactly
the same thing in every context but this
is one where we see something like the
core of the the four itself in terms of
Consciousness at least or in terms of
responsiveness to itself and in itself
life affords it a kind of freedom from
determinism a sort of a temporary
freedom from determinism because it is
intermeshing with a determined and
deterministic outside environment that
it has to somehow fit into
um as a side note too by the way if you
want to see somebody who really took
these sorts of thoughts quite seriously
in a somewhat different context another
dialectical philosophers sometimes
called the French angle or the Catholic
angle you would want to take a look at
Maurice blondel's laxion 1893 because he
is dealing with the same sort of
problematic there at a number of
different levels the the freedom and
determinism uh understood in a different
sense not in the sense that we do in
philosophy of action where freedom and
determinism are somehow Polar Opposites
or somehow perhaps compatible but in a
much more nuanced manner all right
Freedom that is
you might say not just being exercised
in relation to being in itself but is is
actually being produced
we often this is another aside but so
lots of the sides in this this
commentary here but you'll forgive me
for that we often think of Freedom as
something like a property that you have
like you have a certain amount of
freedom and then you dispose of it like
you you spend your monthly income or or
you know
um you you eat you know the amount of
food that's in your your pantry right
Freedom isn't really like that
Freedom exists in part
through its exercise which creates that
very freedom and you can say what is it
created out of and you know in some
respects you can say well nothing I mean
this is where somebody like hiding her
in um what is metaphysics is getting at
something very very fundamental
um and this is a very that's a side note
uh let's come back to this but I think
it's important to keep in mind so we
don't have the wrong conception of
Freedom or rather an inadequate
conception of freedom
sorry
sure you know we often think of it as a
little bit of a digression but it's
worth reflecting on here we often think
of life as something that's sort of
extra it's added on to inorganic nature
it emerges out of it perhaps or you know
it's a extra property Hegel doesn't see
things that way
and this in a certain respect represents
a more ancient view I would say that
says that the higher is really the
origin of the lower not the other way
around
that's because for Hegel the higher has
always been there working at itself
through just not being recognized
um so you know you could have it looking
like it's emergent well even though it
isn't really so or only Is So within a
certain perspective but here's the
syllogism as Hegel lays it out in a
schematic